CATHERINE DRENNAN: I of
course want my students
to be as excited about
chemistry as I am.
And, you know, I feel like MIT
is a relatively serious place.
But the MIT students
are really fun people.
And they're willing to
make fun of themselves
and be a little geeky.
And I love that.
And so whenever I can kind
of encourage something
like that in class, I always
try to take advantage of it.
And one of the
things I like to ask
them is sort of if one geek
is going to propose marriage
to another geek, do you
really give them a diamond?
Or maybe graphite.
Because, you know, one is more
kinetically stable and one's
more thermodynamically stable.
And what's the best gift?
And that often-- then they
can discuss which they think.
And then I'm like,
actually, neither
because what you should give
them is the Green Lantern ring.
And then someone can say, what
about Lord of the Rings ring,
you know.
And so you have-- you can sort
of bring in these [? funs, ?]
but, you know, your
arguments are kind of
based on chemical principles
rather than other things.
So if you can really bring
in sort of the fun humor
that MIT students enjoy, and
they're always with me on that,
and I love that part.
So I'm always looking for
ways to kind of have something
be a little bit more
fun, especially in some
of-- and some of the units, I
feel, really lend themselves
to these fun examples.
And other ones are a
bit more challenging.
But I want to make sure that
everyone has something in.
And if I find something
online or whatever,
I really try to use
that in my class.
And I found these videos
of dogs teaching chemistry,
which at least some
of the students love.
There's always a few MIT
students who are like,
I wish you would just
stick to the facts
and straight derivations.
But for the most part,
I think, attendance
would suggest that students
come and that they're engaged
and that they're seeing
these little things.
And I've discovered
that it really
helps people remember, when
you do something a little bit
different.
One of my favorite things to do
is when I teach about buffers,
I don't know why,
so many students
have trouble with the concept
of buffering, acid base
titrations.
It's just really hard
for a number of people.
So I thought over
the years of ways
that I can really get them
to remember certain things.
And some of it, I can make fun.
Others is have to figure
out how to just make
them memorize certain things.
And really just get them there
where they can just do this
off the top of their head.
And so when I talk
about a buffer,
I always want to make
the point that you
need in your
[INAUDIBLE] buffer, you
need something
that's a weak acid,
and the conjugate of that
is a conjugate weak base.
And you can't just have an
acid, or just have a base.
That won't buffer.
Because you need something.
If you add acid,
you need something
that will buffer it to
keep the pH constant.
If you add base,
you need something
that will-- so it
has to go both ways.
So I like to dress up.
And I have the abbreviation
for a weak acid
taped on the front of my shirt.
And the abbreviation
for the weak base
taped on the back of my shirt.
And I said, I am a buffer.
And I'm an acid, and then
I turn around, I'm a base,
and I turn around again.
I'm an acid.
And I just twirl
around the classroom.
And I said, I want this
engraved in your brain
that a buffer has to have both
a weak acid and a weak base.
And if I keep
twirling like this,
you will try to
purge this memory
from your brain of
Professor Drennan twirling
around the classroom
as an acid and a base,
but you won't be able to.
It'll be with you for
the rest of your life.
You'll be on your
deathbed going please,
can the image of
Professor Drennan
twirling around in
that silly t-shirt
that she made with lab tape,
please, can it leave my brain
now?
But no, no.
It will be with you forever.
And when I do that,
the students do better
on the acid base problems.
So I am OK with really
embarrassing myself.
Whatever it takes, I
go that extra distance
because I want them
to remember that.